hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to handless millionaire - I
am finally back from my long stay in
Ohio where I was just going to see my
family and then my intestines decided
that they wanted to explode so I went to
the hospital and I am all better thank
you guys so much for sending love my way
and understanding that I have been kind
of dying so I'm back in the saddle now I
feel fantastic I'm not dying actually
that was an exaggeration and I'm not on
any painkillers anymore even though I
had surgery just a week ago it was all
laproscopically I've got three new scars
on my belly my belly literally looks
like the Big Dipper right now if you
know what I mean or not know what I mean
because that doesn't make any sense so
this is handless millionaire - which is
a sequel to handless millionaire one
just in case you think - plus - Eagles
chicken and I playing this game because
when I came back from Boston a few weeks
back I played handless millionaire won
and it was a stressful experience and I
[Music]
don't know okay I got okay alright so I
haven't played this game to test it out
because I thought that I would know
exactly what I was supposed to do from
the first game and there's some
differences obviously I'm going to be
grabbing more than one bill and they're
gonna be floating down oh I got a twofer
okay so we're gonna take a mullion on
that one and act like it never happens
so please wipe it from your memories
call men in black again the flashy thing
you in the face and I am going to win
not over and no one's gonna ignore me
and everyone's gonna aerate whatever
okay so I wasn't paying attention and I
kind of forgot because I'm talking
instead of concentrating even though my
hand is at risk here
Alissa's guys not wibbly-wobbly lick
loser Oh
what is that what is that why do I need
a rubber glove is that a drought
incredibly useful down the road instead
of now it's not like one of my lifelines
that I'm gonna be using for this
handless millionaire Anelka oh you
brought it closer well that's different
okay hey this game is so stressful
I mean it's simplistic now what is that
I said Oh armor good do I get to keep
that for the next one because I would
really love to keep that for one I'm
going forward in this game because I
know it's not gonna be good to me
oh they're really only seven rounds Oh
what is this ball crap oh this is some
all here they're getting out of sync oh
oh oh okay there we go
give me give me okay come on come on
it's not gonna stay frozen forever man I
want my money
give me all of you Oh No look here for
what trophy room thousand dollars ray
hooray for me
okay so now I just got to survive for
the rest of it and I should be okay
hopefully Oh what is it bull crap you're
gonna move the thing on me oh god I'm
old I still would never ever ever ever
do this in real life no it's not worth
it it would not be worth losing your
goddamn hand good kind of oh man I'm
already up to six hundred and fifty
seven thousand dollars oh boy can I go
home now oh you won't Oh God
Oh God Jerry I got a million I got a
million dollars oh oh this one left hand
shakes more I don't want it oh boy I'll
crap escapes all harder than the other
one ah
our doctors do not remain you recommend
you play any longer I want to win I've
won the last one I got a [ __ ] out of
place I gotta fight back Oh at least I
have all my money
let's get for me my name is Marky you
[Applause]
freak you bastards give me the money
give me the money come on crap
yes
and do it good you're good
okay I did I did I did I did it okay I
did it I did it I did it I'm back into
round six I think what happened last
time was that I panicked too much
because I'm a spaz I can't deal with the
pain oh god this game is just so
stressful
hello all what is this [ __ ] is that
a completely random ass thing give a
gimme the money freeze off your pants
and gamma Devon a I want about it give
me the money put your money in my face
[Applause]
at least my name is Sally my scientist I
did it cut oh man it's more like I went
to play horror games goddamn that son of
a [ __ ] okay so I am now back in LA
which means that the video upload
schedule is going to be as good as it
was before I had all these conventions
to go to and we're gonna have a fun time
with the videos but I mean I just wanted
to say again thank you guys so much for
sending all the love walls in the
hospital and going through the surgery
and all that I didn't want to scare
anyone because you know I didn't want to
say oh my god I wasn't like dying dying
it was one of those things where if
modern medicine didn't exist if I was
like born in the 1600s and this happened
I would have been dead same with
appendix and all that but modern
medicine makes everything relatively
easy except hospital visits are never
fun an NG tube sock if you've ever had
an NG tube oh you know what I mean
I had to get one of those put in when I
was awake disgusting story I'm not gonna
recite it here just thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want to see
the first part of this game you can
check out the description below or the
annotation over there thanks again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]
needs to be properly handled such that
you can go about your daily life knowing
that everything Oh God